[Hangout dings]
>>Ankur Kotwal: Hello and welcome everyone
to another Android Developer Lab+.
We will be getting started in just a minute.
I'm just setting up the Google Developer's
live link so just bear with us and we'll be
right back.
>>Tony Chen: Yeah, hi everyone.
[Typing on keyboard]
>>Ankur Kotwal: Okay and we're good to go.
So if you're tuning in online live right now,
then you should be able to go to developers.google.com/live
and go to ADL+.
So, let's start off with the usual introductions.
I am Ankur Kotwal and I'm joining you from
Sydney, Australia.
I'm also joined by my colleague and friend.
>>Tony Chen: Hi, I'm Tony Chen from China.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Tony is muted right now so
we can't hear him but he'll fix that up in
a second.
[Laughs]
>>Tony Chen: Okay, can you, can you hear me
now?
>>Ankur Kotwal: We still can't hear him.
So let me introduce Tony in the meanwhile
it's Tony Chen from Hong Kong and one of our
regular viewers, Andrew, has just joined us
as well.
Hi, Andrew.
>>Andrew Kelly: Hi.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Okay.
Alright, Tony.
I cannot, Andrew are you able to hear Tony?
>>Tony Chen: Can you hear me?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Now we can.
>>Andrew Kelly: I can, yep.
>>Tony Chen: Okay, yeah, so I'm Tony Chen
joining the hangout from Hong Kong and today
we have the special topic for today is density
independent pixel.
Before that let's talk, uh, let me share my
screen.
Hopefully this time we're doing it right.
Just give me a second.
[Pause]
>>Tony Chen: So, can everyone see the slide
alright?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yep, looks good here, Tony.
>>Tony Chen: Okay, great.
So, let's talk about, um, before we get to
the DP subject today, let's talk about news.
So, for this week we have ADT 21 Preview 3.
It's mostly bufixes and no new feature but
if you want to check it out, as always, like,
just go to tools.android.com.
In other news this week is our colleague,
Roman Nurik has made a G+ post about chips
and recipient text field.
So this is what you guys usually see on the
Google Plus client and Roman has some details,
information about how, where you can get the
code from the AOSP website.
So check that out.
I have a Google short link here, so, check
it out.
>>Ankur Kotwal: just to give you a background
on that, we call it 'chips' but it's basically
when you, when you complete some contact information,
rather than have the email address or the
phone number show up, you get a nice little
rectangular box with an image of the avatar
of that person in that box and their name.
So instead of just having an ascetic email
address, it's a much more pleasant piece of
UI and you can, you know, select that whole
chip, if you wanna clear it or if you wanna
add a few more people and drag it around,
that sort of thing.
So it's just, uh, just a nice bit of polish
to add to your apps and those are the little
subtle differences that really make your app
stand out compared to others.
So Roman has basically, in his post, shown
you where you can find it in the Android Open
Source projects so the source code is already
there he's just showing you exactly where
to look.
>>Tony Chen: Cool.
Alright, so, let's get to the topic of today,
density independent pixel.
So before we get to the details about what
that is and what DP is let's start with an
overview, um, to just get everyone on the
same page with some definitions.
So, screen size is actually the physical size
of any devices, any Android devices.
So we have four categories, small, normal,
large and extra large.
And then when we talk about screen density
it's really the, it's the quantity of pixel
within a physical area of the screen.
So, a lot of people use dot per inch, this
is the common terminology.
And for resolution, it's closely related to
screen density but it's really talking about
the total number of physical pixel on the
screen.
So when we talk about screen density and resolution
is really the, in proportional, the higher
the screen density, the higher the resolution.
So what is the problem with pixel?
Because, as like you guys already know, we
introduced something called deep density independent
pixel in Android and we highly recommend everyone
when you design layout using DP style pixel
but was this really the problem with pixel?
Well, turn out pixel has many meanings.
And what I'm really mean by that is like,
let's go to the pixel, like the definition
of pixel.
It's really based on the contraction of pix,
which is coming from picture, and the E-L
is coming from element.
So it's really an element of the smallest
addressable element for display.
But then when we talk about printer, pixel
can be an ink droplet or even a unit of carbon
particles.
So, as you can see, there are many different
meanings based on the context.
And in camera, pixel is really represent an
image sensor element.
So it's really different meaning depends on
the terminology or context.
Pixel can also have different size and representation
because a pixel in CRT monitor is different
from a pixel from a LCD screen.
So, if you want to know more about the detail
of pixel, you can go to wikipedia to find
out even more detail.
So, now we have density independent pixel.
So, the key here is DP is really a physical
length unit, so, just like centimeter or meter.
So you have a physical length in the real
world.
And, of course, like one thing we, in the
very beginning we use, actually, dip as shorthand
but now it's dp and dip is,are interchangeable
and you can still identify things in your
layout with both shorthand.
Pixel is also a physical point but then it
doesn't have a fixed dimension.
So it varies, depends on technology and how
a particular device has, it may have many
pixel in the same length.
So, we have a definition or a formula to trans-,
um, to translate between pixel and dp and
the formula is here is a pixel is equal to
dp star times the dpi over 160.
And 160 is really kinda like the magic number
because that is the density for mdpi.
So in Android, we have different screen densities
listed here below here, its ldpi, mdpi, hdpi,
etcetera.
And the one I highlight in red, the tvdpi,
is particularly interesting at the moment
because it's the, well first of all it's the
tvdpi for Google TV and also as well as like
the latest Android tablet, Nexus 7, density
as well.
So, now after we learn all these, like, concept,
let's get to some exercise.
So, how many pixels are there in 1dp for our
first Android phone, the G1 phone?
Can someone make a guess?
It turns out the answer is 1 pixel and the
reason is we used the G1 as the baseline for
everything basically the G1 phone is the normal,
is a normal screen size and also have the
mdpi resolution, sorry about the typo there.
Let's get to another exercise.
How many pixels are there in 1dp for an xhdpi
device?
Guess what?
The answer is, it depends.
[chuckles] Because for xhdpi is, actually,
it's a range and in most cases xhdpi is 320
but it depends on what device, could be, some
device could have like 325 or things like
that so that's why it depends.
And that actually makes this coming exercise
easy because now I specified the density of
this xhdpi device to 320 and, of course, the
answer here is 2 pixel.
Um, okay, so another exercise, so, what are
the dimensions in dp for the following rectangles?
So if you look at these rectangles and if
you remember our definition of a dp which
is, I actually put the formula up there for
convenience and if you remember the mdpi is
the baseline, which is 160, the answer is,
will be obvious and the answer is 4dp.
And because we are, for the rectangle of an
mdpi we have 4 pixels on each side and because
that's the baseline and we have 4 pixels and
the answer, and that makes the answer 4dp.
Okay, so, another thing I want to talk about
is the dpi ratio because as you can see from
the formula, it's really the current density
of your device divided by 160 and because
of the, there are actually ratio between these
different density and just a convenient thing
to remember is like 3 to 4 to 6 to 8 so you
can use these ratio easily to do the proper
conversion to get pixel or dps based on these,
like, ratios.
Okay, so, let's talk about the problem of
using pixel, px, in your, in your layout.
So here is an example of the effect of defining
a 2x2 box in pixel in your layout.
So, as you can see, if you do it, if you define
something with pixel, in the ldpi device,
it occupies the entire rectangle but as you
move to different devices you see the graph,
the box actually is shrinking because you
define things in pixel and in the higher density
device, the pixel is actually smaller and
that's the reason why things are not scaled
properly in, in, when you define things in
pixel.
So now let's take a look at the effect when
you define things in dp.
So, in this case, because you defined things
in dp, and as I mentioned before and hopefully
you'll already remember dp is a physical length
unit, so if you define something with two
dp, the representation across different resolution
is the same, it's going to be the same.
And that's what we meant by resolution independent.
Okay, so, what about bitmap assets?
So the Android framework actually is quite
intelligent and it will scale bitmap drawables
appropriately when using dp.
But there is a big caveat here.
The graphics here, as you can see, it doesn't
matter whether you're scaling up or scaling
down because there's no algorithm, actually,
perfect algorithm that would produce to scaling
images.
So if you scale up you will, because you don't
have enough information, you have to do interpolation
and that will create an image that is not
sharp.
But, at the same time, if you're scaling down
your image there's a potential running into
something called aliasing which also can make
your image not sharp at all also.
So, the conclusion here is you should create
bitmap resources for each dens-, uh, density
of device you're targeting.
So, what is sp?
Because besides dp there is also sp in Android.
So sp is something we designed specifically
for text.
In the Android framework there is accessibility
option to allow user to enlarge fonts even
they are specified in dp.
So, in that case, the formula is really, sp
is really dp times some scaling factor determined
by the user, what kind of font, uh, scale
they want to scale their fonts to, to larger
fonts or smaller fonts.
So it's still somehow [indistinct] the dp,
make the text a kind of independent of resolution
but at the same time if the user decides to
scale it up for accessibility reasons there
is an [indistinct] scaling factor for user
to specify.
And after all these, so I hope by now you
have a, kind of a good grasp of what dp is
and because of all these, like, problem that
pixel and that's why we kind of introduced
a new size qualifier to do, to do resource
classification.
And this new qualifier allows more control
over different specific, like, screen sizes
to support your application.
So, the old size qualifier which is small,
normal, medium, large, extra large, and turns
out because of the resolution issue it's no
longer good enough to classify things like
tablets.
So, for example, a seven inch tablet has a
size large but so, that makes actually tablet
not necessarily equals extra large which is,
breaks a lot of things and by introducing
these new qualifiers, so there are three of
them, so one of them we call it smallest width
so the syntax is right, is like sw and then
the number and then the dp.
So the nice things about this smallest width
is you don't need to care about the orientation
of your device so all, all you are specifying
here is for a particular device, for the smallest
width size of the tablet or the device, it
has to be at least 600dp in this case.
So, in that case, the resource under this
resource folder will be selected for creating
your lay-, um, rendering the layout.
There are two other qualifiers, one is specifically
for width and another one for height but it's
tricky because, it really ups to the [indistinct]
like to find which size is the width and which
size is the height and we usually see and
recommend people using the smallest width
and that should take care of a lot of the
cases.
Um, so, one thing about compatibility, so,
before we introduce, uh, before Honeycomb
3.2, these qualifiers doesn't exist, right?
So, in that case, we still recommend developer,
especially if you are targeting pre Honeycomb
devices, you still need to specify a bucket
to take care of selecting tablets using extra
large, for example.
But in this case there's one problem, you
can, as you can see, there are two files,
actually having the same tablet layout, the
main activity xml is actually duplicate.
So, how to solve this problem, so, one thing
you can do is you can abstract out the tablet
layout into a different user, uh, using a
different name, uh, in this case I call it
main activity tablet.xml.
And for, in your, in your resource folder
under, using values, you can specify layout
pointing to that particular xml.
So I understand, like, the layout xml is still
duplicates but your content, your true layout
is only defined once, so, which is the key
here.
Finally, let's talk a little bit about screen
support.
So in, we have a tool tags in the Android
framework to allow multiple screen support
so one of them is support of screen and in
this case here I want to filter out small
and normal screen size.
So, this is the, kind of the, the specification
I need to do to set small screen and normal
screen to force.
So, how bout this one?
So, is this the configuration to filter out
small, only make the, your application available
for small or normal size screen?
Well, it turns out the answer is wrong because
the support screen doesn't mean that your
application will not be available but for
large and extra large device.
It just mean that they're running in something
we call compatibility mode for these two form
factors.
So, how to filter out large or extra large
screen devices?
We have another tag that actually can really
do this, so, in this case here you are using
something called compatible screen tag and
you have to specify all the screen you would
like to support.
So that's the one big caveat and that's kind
of the reason why we are not recommending
developer to use this because you, if you
don't specify all the different combination
you'll, your application will not be available
for those you didn't specify.
And another thing is after all, in Android
we always looking for application that support
all devices and that should be your ultimate
goal.
So that's pretty much for density independent
pixel and so we can switch to Q and A or Ankur
if you have anything to add to this feel free
to chime in.
>>Ankur Kotwal: No, that was quite comprehensive.
[chuckles]
>>Tony Chen: Cool.
>>Ankur Kotwal: So at this stage I guess we
can, given that we've just had a topic that
we, that Tony presented are there any questions
on the presentation from any of the live audience
or anyone tuning into the stream even?
>>Tony Chen: Yeah?
>>male #1: Hi, I would like to ask you about
pictures and images loading from the internet,
for example, Facebook.
So if Facebook has a large image, say, 180
pixels, on large devices with hdpi they will
be displayed as twice, so it will be like
90dpi?
Any way to, any strategies to like scale them?
>>Tony Chen: Oh, so, I think in that case,
back to the presentation, is if you define
your image dimension using dp, the Android
framework will automatically actually scale
the image up for you.
But then, again, you run into the issue of
interpolation, you may, you will not have
a perfect image and that's why we suggest
developer to create different accents in the
right resolution for that particular density.
>>Ankur Kotwal: As a just general strategy,
though, if you're pulling, and in your situation
you said you were pulling down assets from
the net and you might not have, you know,
a different, um, resolutions of those images,
consider whether you think stretch, stretching
that image is really the right thing to do
and certainly consider whether you wanna stretch
it to as big as you can get.
There might be a middle ground that makes
more sense like, you know, 1.5 times in every
dimension where it doesn't look too blurry
but, you know, it is what it is.
So if your source image is low resolution
there's only so much that you're gonna be
able to do with it.
>>male #1: Okay, thank you.
>>Ankur Kotwal: There was a question, there
was a couple of questions on the moderator
that have been added, Tony, on this topic
so let's deal with those ones first then today.
"Is it possible and how to provide different
graphics, except 9 patches for two different
devices running, for example, 800 by 480 and
540 by 960 on Android two and 2.3 without
checking the resolution via Java source and
setting the proper graphics."
So, my understanding of this question is the
person is asking how do I make it scale without
having to manually do it myself.
Is that your understanding, Tony?
>>Tony Chen: Uh, yeah, based on what the question
is.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, so what I would suggest
is actually just if you're just going to render
it in a view just use, like, an image view,
just use the properties that we provide there
that allow but you can specify whether you
want it to stretch to fit or you want it to
scale or you want it to crop.
There's a couple of options there that you
should really have a look at and see what
makes sense.
So, in that case, the Android framework is
doing the work for you.
So, just keep in mind, however, though as
I, as we just said to Constantine that it
may not make sense to always stretch to low
res image to a bigger [inaudible].
In terms of providing the best user experience
cause that's the goal at the end of the day,
you might have to have some logic in there
that says hey if I'm pulling down some image
from an online source and I don't know what
resolution it will be do I wanna make it bigger
than it is or do I wanna shrink it so on and
so forth.
If you're providing your own assets, um, as
long as you're kind of reasonably in the ball
park I would probably try and render the image
slightly higher than it needs to be and then
put it in the, in the relevant resolution
bucket and then just size my UI based on dp's
just like Tony described today.
>>Tony Chen: Yeah.
I think the second question we have on moderator
is, "Whenever we read the dimension of device
screen, example, 480 times 800, 1024 times
600, in the device specification is that valid
in pixel, dp or dip?"
So, uh, wow, my understanding those number
are in pixel and also the other thing is dp
and dip is the same thing.
Yeah, so, um.
>>Ankur Kotwal: I think that was a trick question
to try and catch us out, Tony.
So we picked it up.
>>Tony Chen: Exactly.
[Laughter]
>>Tony Chen: Yeah and one thing I want to,
I want to comment is when we've talked about,
like, designing layout in dp, it's really,
what we are talking about is we want the experience
on a particular physical size consistent regardless
of resolution.
So, we are not saying, like, using dp in your
layout will scale properly in different size
device.
That actually is a misconception.
So what we are talking about here is if you
design a 7 inch layout for a 7 inch device
and if you are specifying all these dimension
in dp, it will guarantee to work on all the
7 inches devices regardless of resolution
and that's the power of dp.
It's not, we're not saying if you define a
7 inch layout using dp it will work in the
10 inch device, that's not true and you have,
uh, what you should do is you should define
a layout for a 10 inch in form factor and
you may choose to use, like, using more [unclear]
or using different design and things should
still be done in dp so that your layout will
work on 10 inch device with a different resolution.
So that's the, that's the key concept here.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, I might just add to
that, Tony, I think in general-, my experience
has been that 7 inch devices and 10 inch devices
you can actually reuse the same layout, in
general, and it works really well and it scales
nicely.
I mean, assuming you're building nice scalable
user interfaces.
One big differentiating factor that I find
between 7 inch tablets and 10 inch tablets,
however, is that the default orientation of
a 10 inch tablet is landscape mode whereas
the default orientation for most of the, just
about all the 7 inch tablets I've seen is
portrait mode.
So that's something you should consider as
to how, what your layout, how your layout
might change between portrait mode and landscape
mode.
To me, the big differentiating factor is actually
the orientation as opposed to the physical
size of the screen.
>>Tony Chen: Right.
I mean, like, if you do things like write
using fill_parent or wrap con-, for, for the
container so things will flow properly when
you go from a 7 inch to a 10 inch device.
But one thing to remember is if you specify
things in dp those assets or controls will
stay the same size regardless of the, the
7inch or 10 inch.
So, but if you do the container or the layout
container properly then they will, they will,
or doing, using percentage and things will
work fine.
>>Ankur Kotwal: So I think that's all the
questions that we had on this week's topic
so Tony thanks for covering dps.
The one thing we talked about was sort of
the advantages of dp but the big take away
I think developers should really go back with
is don't use pixels in your layout.
Don't specify user interfaces with pixels
because that's not going to scale across the
wide ecosystem of devices that we have.
You know, build scalable user interfaces and
dps are certainly one way to do that.
The other way of building sort of flexible
user interfaces is using things like wrap
content or fill_parent on your layouts as
well.
>>Tony Chen: Right.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Alright, so we've got three
other questions on here, Tony.
I'll just take them from the top.
>>Tony Chen: Sure.
>>Ankur Kotwal: "I'm implementing in app billing
but when I try to buy some item in the sample
app, I don't get a response from my app and
after a few minutes I get an error of reason
took too long to deliver.
This bug was in the known issues for almost
a year, is there an update?"
I didn't know it was a known issue and certainly
I've played with in app billing and I haven't
had this particular issue.
So, I don't know if you've got more to add
Tony but it'd be great if this person, "BRNO",
would contact us separately and just let us
know what the issue, if she or he has got
a bug raised.
>>Tony Chen: I'm not aware that there is a
bug but one thing that may cause that reason,
took too long to deliver, is some of the transaction
orders is actually maybe flagged as fraud
or, you know, from a risk engine.
So I think one thing developers should have
expectation is there are a certain percentage
of orders that will be flagged as potential
risk fraud.
And for those orders it will not process go
through and that's a result, could be a result
of that took too long and-
>>Ankur Kotwal: It shouldn't happen in the
test app, though, cause if he's using, he
or she are using that sample app it should
be using the package names that are using
the test nomenclature.
>>Tony Chen: Okay.
>>Ankur Kotwal: So, the risk engine site shouldn't
come into play but I'd love to hear from-
>>Tony Chen: But there are, there are developers,
like, telling some transactions have failing
so, may not be this case here but that could
be a potential problem.
Sometimes if you see these transactions didn't
go through and I hate to say it, it's normal
but it does happen, like, some transactions
does, won't go through for risk reason.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah.
Cool, so please do contact Tony or myself
and we can have a deeper dive in it.
I guess we'd need to see a little bit more
as to exactly what you're doing and we can
try and take it from there.
Okay, "According to the Google Cloud Messaging
tutorial, awake lock is required in order
to handle the registration action.
How can the device handle registration response
but in sleep mode when sending a request to
a third party server?
Any other examples of services requiring awake
lock?"
>>Tony Chen: Um, I know of an example.
So, we have an Open Source project called
Prone to Phone and there should be implementation
on the things you described.
In terms of getting, handle registration responding
in sleep mode, Ankur, I don't know the andswer.
Do you have any insight on this, this part?
>>Ankur Kotwal: No, I mean, I think in general
it's good practice to acquire the awake lock
if you're waiting for a response because these
things, your request responses are asynchronous
in nature.
So if you actually wanted to make sure that
you are, you know, awake so to speak, for
that duration then you should do so.
Just be careful in terms of acquiring that
awake lock because you wanna try and minimize
how long you've got it for because, of course,
the device is not able to sleep at that point
in time so it's a drain on the battery.
>>Tony Chen: Yeah, I agree.
So the third question, the last question,
oh, you have a question?
>>male #1: Yeah, yeah, I'd like to add more
about this question.
For example, I have foreground service which
uses a website that's a connection to the
server and definitely the user can push the
power button to, for the device to go into
sleep mode.
Does it mean that I still need to acquire
awake lock so the connection won't be broken?
>>Ankur Kotwal: If you want to maintain the
persistence of your connection then I would
recommend, yes, but I would also ask you to
really think about whether that connection
needs to be persistent, persisted throughout
and that's one of the benefits of Google Cloud
Messaging aright, so you don't have to have
awake lock the whole time or a connection
to your server you can have a notification
come through or a message come through and
then you can spring to action then.
It's event based rather than you having to
maintain this persistent connection.
>>male #1: Okay, thank you.
>>Tony Chen: Okay, so the last question we
have here is, "Can you recommend the best
way to implement themes in Android since you
point to cover dpi and other related topics
maybe you can consider having an info about
themes, too."
So, first of all, that's a great suggestion
and I think, like, theme itself could be another
ADL+ presentation so definitely we'll look
into that and hopefully we'll have another
session about themes, specifically, in the
future.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, in the meantime, though,
we've actually got a fairly extensive section
on developer.android.com in the guide section
on styles and themes and it walks you through,
sort of, how to style, do some basic styling.
I think that's a great place to get started.
There are more, sort of, community based examples
that I've seen that go to a larger extent
so I'd seen a community effort for building
the hollow theme for older Android versions,
for example.
So, what I suggest is to start with this guide
and then go have a look at some of these community
efforts and see how people are building, you
know, building advanced themes so to speak.
But yes, thanks for the suggestion.
I think that's a good idea for a future topic
as well.
>>Tony Chen: Yep.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Okay, well, anyone else have
any questions?
>>Andrew Kelly: I had one.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, go ahead.
[Pause]
>>Tony Chen: Go ahead.
>>Andrew Kelly: [inaudible]
>>Ankur Kotwal: There you go.
Now we can hear you.
>>Andrew Kelly: I just have one from the chat
window there, when I'm using 9-patches, do
I need to specify a PNG file for each of the
different DPI buckets or do I just need to
have one in my drawable folder that will cover
me for everything?
>>Ankur Kotwal: I think you could get away
with just having the one.
I wouldn't put it the drawable folder, we
actually have one called the drawable-nodpi
which is kind of like the explicit one to
say that this applies to every bucket.
I mean, it will work but just from a best
practices point of view we recommend using
the no dpi nomenclature.
>>Andrew Kelly: Cool.
>>Tony Chen: Yeah.
I think using 9 patches would, it can be another
topic so in the future we can talk about it.
[Laughter]
>>Andrew Kelly: I just wanted to make sure
that I didn't need to have, sort of, a high
res 9 patch for high res devices in a sort
of low res-
>>Ankur Kotwal: Potentially you can.
Depends on how big the image is, right?
>>Andrew Kelly: Yeah.
>>Ankur Kotwal: So if you're doing it for
styling, you know, UI then maybe you can get
away without it but if you're doing, you know,
high res images that you're expecting to stretch
like a background
>>Andrew Kelly: Just things like buttons and
things like that so at the moment I've been
using, defining them in xml using gradients
and stuff and strokes so I don't have to have
a 9 patch instead and that seems to work quite
well . So I was just thinking I needed a more
fancy button that couldn't be defined using
a gradient then I might have to use 9 patches.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, you'd probab-, I mean,
ideally you should have, you should be building
assets for each of those res-, each of those
buckets, but if it's something really small,
like your 9-patch is really tiny then it might
be overkill.
There is no, I don't think it's an exact science
so you kind of have to use your judgment as
to what, at what point you should sort of
break the cord and say no I do need to build
specific nine patches for each of those buckets.
>>Andrew Kelly: Cool.
Cheers.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Alright.
We've just had one other person join.
>>male #1: Can I ask one more question about
the layouts?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, absolutely.
>>male #1: So going back to my question, it
was a question about images from net.
For example, if I have an image 160 pixels,
so is it the best option to set the maximum
width like G1 devices or 400 dpi?
Otherwise it will be like more than a half
screen width, and leave it as is for hdpi
devices in the image view.
>>Ankur Kotwal: So just so I make sure that
I've understood your question, do you mean
whether you should scale the image down or
shrink it so that it's not occupying too much
physical space on the device?
>>male #1: Yeah.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, I would, I would definitely
do that.
I would shrink it where possible.
I mean, where it makes sense.
So there is some work that you need to do
if you're pulling assets from some remote
server that, whose resolution you don't have
any control over.
As to what makes sense for your UI, so if
it only makes sense for your, you know, whatever
it is to be only 30 percent of the width of
the screen then that's going to, you know,
that 30 percent, the actual number of, the
size of it is going to differ depending on
which you're running on.
So, yeah, absolutely you'd wanna scale that.
Things like linear layouts can help there
because you can set weights and so on and
have it done for you but it really depends
how custom built your UI is and how much control
you're exerting over it.
>>Andrew Kelly: Is that what the scale type
is for on the image view to say send to fit
or send to crop?
That kind of stuff?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah.
That's exactly right, yeah.
But on top of that if you, so if you're doing
it based on weights then you need the linear
layout weights to come through as well over
and above that, right?
But the scale type will definitely say, you
know, hey if my view is bigger than the image
then what should I do with it?
So, yeah.
>>male #1: Thanks.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Alright, well, if there is
nothing else thank you for joining us this
week.
I suspect that we are going to, we're not
going to run the ADL+ next week because of
a scheduling conflict but we will be back
soon and, yeah, again keep the feedback coming.
We've had quite a few suggestions for topics
that we should cover in the future and we
are definitely taking that on board and prioritizing
accordingly.
>>male #2: Hello?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Oh, hi there.
>>male #2: Hi, can I have one question, one
more question?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, absolutely.
>>male #2: I'm the guy with the in app billing
problem.
You responded before and I have one question.
My first payment was from a credit card where
I don't have enough money and that can be
a problem and when I run a different card
and after some more payments I've got cancellation
of this payment.
Can it be DOS problem?
If you understand?
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, so, Tony do you wanna
grab this one?
>>male #2: I can show you some screen share.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, just be careful of not
showing any of your credit card details cause
that won't be a good thing.
[Laughter]
>>Tony Chen: Maybe we can do this off line
you can-
>>male #2: I can show, it's no problem.
>>Ankur Kotwal: No, I don't think we should,
actually.
I think we, I think it's better that we don't.
>>Tony Chen: Let's do that offline.
>>male #2: Okay.
>>Ankur Kotwal: When it comes to payment that
sort of stuff can be quite sensitive so what
I'd suggest is, look, we'll wrap up the ADL+
here and let's solve, Tony and I will contact
you straight afterwards and we'll continue
our discussion through that.
>>male #2: Okay, thank you.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Thank you everyone.
>>Tony Chen: Thank you.